hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's edition of what I
eat a day you'd review is sponsored by
Squarespace and I'm going to be taking a
look at Victoria's Secret model and
youtuber Romi stride now if you're not
familiar with Squarespace it is an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store or use their
marketing tools and analytics as a
blogger myself I love that Squarespace
has a number of SEO tools to really take
the guesswork out of making your site
Google friendly and it also has
appointment scheduling tools for online
booking or coordinating calendars
I also obviously do a lot on social
media so bloggers will also really find
the social sharing buttons super helpful
while also setting up email campaigns
for mailing lists when everything in
your digital presence works together
like this it makes it so much easier for
you to really just focus on your actual
business you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com slash Abby sharp to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain okay so now let's talk about
Romi this video was highly requested
especially after I reviewed another
Victoria's Secret model sand flowy so I
knew that I really had to get to it ASAP
for your Quarantine enjoyment now on
Romy's channel you'll find a ton of
vlogs about life as a model some travel
Diaries workouts and of course what she
eats now Before we jump into my review I
want to start with my general disclaimer
that the information in this video is
for entertainment and educational
purposes only and you should always
speak to a health care professional or
registered dietitian about your unique
health care needs I also want to let you
all know that based on your feedback
I've switched up the way that I'm
organizing these videos to focus
basically on all of day one then all of
day two then all of day three so if
you're liking this format definitely
leave me a comment below
let me know okay I wanted to hop in here
because at the time this video is being
edited Romi posted a very exciting
announcement so I want to say a huge
congrats to Romi and her partner
Lauren's I know the horrible
disappointment of thinking that you
might not be able to conceive and also
of getting a diagnosis like PCOS which
is a condition that I've covered here on
Abby's kitchen right here I also want to
applaud Romi for admitting that this may
have been the result of under eating and
over exercising as I'm sure that was
really hard to come to terms with now
without further ado let's meet Romi
morning I brought my own breakfast I
made chia pudding last night so I am
glad to hear that she's trying to cut
back on caffeine is at one point she
mentioned she used to drink five to six
cups a day I think I would die but well
some people are more sensitive to
caffeine than others research does
suggest that there may be risks
associated with consuming six cups of
coffee or more in a day including things
like anxiety sleep disturbances
increased blood pressure and elevated
heart rate so again I'm happy to see
that she's taking some steps in the
right direction to help lower her
caffeine intake to a more appropriate
amount most evidence does suggest that
up to 400 milligrams of caffeine a day
is considered safe for most people which
would equal up to about four small cups
of coffee
however this recommendation is lower for
some people who are particularly
sensitive to caffeine or who are
pregnant or taking certain medications
as for real nice breakfast I think it's
great that she's kind of prepped her own
meal for the shoot even though she knows
it's going to be catered I am all about
being prepared and planning ahead when
you can when it's something that is
feasible for you because sometimes when
you're going to an event or to a work
function you have just no idea what or
when food is going to be served if
anything is served at all and this just
means that you can make more mindful
thoughtful decisions about when and what
to eat based on your unique needs I also
think that her chia pudding is a great
breakfast option I mean the Chia
provides a ton of fiber and omega-3 fats
and she's got extra protein from the
protein powder and the nuts I mean it
wouldn't hurt to see maybe a little bit
more carbs maybe just adding in some
more berries or like a banana on top but
overall this looks pretty good to me
let's take a look at her snack some
people like to only do three big meals
in a day and just like five or six that
is a nice big juicy looking apple so an
apple is a fine snack if that is what
you're craving and you know you're not
super hungry but I would say if you
really want to boost up the satiety
factor you know I like to pair mine with
some protein or some healthy fats so
maybe some nut butter or cheese or seeds
I am definitely hearing that Romy finds
having regular meals and snacks is
really important to her for really
maintaining that sense of satiety and I
just think that you know adding a little
extra staying powder in addition to
those carbs in the Apple would really
help her achieve that let's take a look
at lunch looks like this and it has
seared salmon
avocado Coosh Coosh string bean some
purple cabbage it's some kind of and I
do tend to eat a lot of because it keeps
me full
okay so Romy had initially brought her
own lunch meal to the shoot like she had
done with her chia pudding breakfast but
she decided to forego her homemade meal
and go for the catering because it just
sounded good I really like
Romy's flexibility here and I mean who
hasn't ditched their homemade lunch when
they saw their buddies having something
better so totally makes sense I'm not
sure what she had originally planned for
lunch but this bowl looks amazing
you know we've got lots of healthy fats
and protein from the salmon more healthy
fats from the avocado we've got some veg
in there some cars from the couscous no
complaints let's check out snack - so
we're back with another snack and Romi
is having kind of like a blueberry acai
bowl thing top with some granola coconut
flakes and goji berries it is definitely
nice to see a model who is not afraid of
carbs but I would say like for a
pre-dinner snack I still would have
liked to see maybe some protein you know
even just following her own nutritional
recommendations which I know she talks
about throughout her videos but overall
solid substantial looking snack let's
hit up dinner okay so for dinner Romy
and her partner order a variety of sushi
rolls including avocado mushroom
cucumber tuna and salmon plus edamame oh
now I am really missing my pre isolation
pre pregnancy weeknight sushi dates I
swear you're worth it baby I swear
anyways I really do think that you know
sushi takeout is usually pretty balanced
as a meal just in general
edamame for instance is an excellent
source of plant-based protein we also
have a variety of different roles here
with a combination veggies carbs from
the rice and protein and healthy fats
from the tuna and the salmon the only
thing that I would recommend when it
comes to ordering sushi takeout is to
try to go easy on the soy sauce one
tablespoon of soy has roughly a thousand
milligrams of sodium which is about 67%
of your daily sodium recommendation and
we all know how easy it is to like soap
a single roll in that stuff so whenever
possible I always ask for reduced sodium
soy but even the low-sodium varieties
still have about 600 milligrams of
sodium per tablespoon so don't go around
thinking that reduce sodium necessarily
means low sodium so just learn to kind
of keep in the back of your mind since
eating foods that are higher in sodium
may cause you to feel a little bit more
bloated a little more uncomfortable
after a meal all right now on that note
let's move along today - I always start
my day with the hot water with lemon it
has a lot of vitamin C and it's just
really refreshing in the morning
whenever I eat this or drink this
actually it just gives me like a healthy
feeling so I kind of think it helps me
with like the mindset for the rest of
the day and I just squeeze half a lemon
in hot water I also think it's really
good for your digestion so when you
drink it on an empty stomach it like
kick starts okay of course you know
lemon water might as well be like the
official wellness influencer mascot
seeing us so many influencers I review
start their day with lemon water in an
effort to boost digestion but does this
actually work well one thing to consider
is the role of bile acid when you eat
fatty foods bile acids are secreted from
the gallbladder and lemon juice slowly
increases bile acid secretion but unless
you have an issue with your gallbladder
there is really no need to help it out
with any lemon juice now the other thing
is the ID
a citric acid and lemon juice
supplements your stomach acid to break
down food but again unless you have an
actual condition like hypochloride ria
and you cannot produce stomach acid your
body just does it perfectly on demand
every time
no supplementation needed then there's
the idea that acidic foods like lemons
slow the rate of gastric emptying which
is true but this won't necessarily help
with digestion as much as it will with
nutrient absorption and we actually have
no research on lemon juices roll on this
or how much lemon juice you would
actually need to consume to see a
difference well we actually have a lot
more evidence on is the fact that foods
high in fiber protein and fat also help
with this and if you're just having
water I'm not really sure why you need
to delay gastric emptying period and
then finally there's this idea that
lemons have fiber so they are good for
digestion in general this is true kinda
in that the pulp has soluble fiber as
does the pith and the skin but you would
need to consume a crap-ton of lemon pulp
to get even a modest dose of fiber and
there are way better sources for a
morning drink so folks can we please put
the lemon water myth to bed okay so now
that I've completely torn apart that
common wellness concept I need to say
that if lemon water is something that ro
me genuinely enjoys in the morning
because it helps to shift her into a
healthy mindset I think that's a great
idea a lot of people find that what they
do or eat in the morning can kind of set
up their intentions for the rest of the
day so if this is helpful I think it's
an awesome plan and honestly any water
is good water in my books let's take a
look at breakfast
so I put the oatmeal in here and I just
like oh man so much because it's really
high in fiber and it has a lot of like
good carbs so it keeps me full so long
like until lunchtime and makes up like
goji berries pumpkin seeds I think
they're mill berries in there just a lot
of like different different kind of
seeds then the next stopping I pick
today is chia seeds I sprinkle some
cinnamon because I heard cinnamon is
helping to keep your blood sugar in
control so I feel like when you eat it
with fruits it really helps okay so YUM
this oatmeal is super Instagram Abul and
loaded with tons of nutritious stuff
we've got complex carbs from the oats a
good amount of protein from the peanut
butter and seeds healthy fats from the
Chia and nuts I'm loving it
I also love that she swings her oatmeal
naturally with a banana which is a hack
that I use all the time especially with
my son's foods where you know I don't
want to add too much added sugar totally
delish and a super balanced breakfast
which I am really happy to see and it's
a solid breakfast portion so no skimping
here love it I will say that Romi
clearly seems to factor in the
nutritional value of a lot of the
ingredients that she adds to her meals
so for instance she does mention at one
point that chia seeds are high in
omega-3 fats and oats are high in fiber
and help to keep her really full in fact
I will say that the desire to stay full
is something that Romi talks about a lot
in her videos and we're gonna get more
into that in a little bit but she also
mentions adding cinnamon to her meals to
help control blood sugar so let's focus
our attention on that so cinnamon has
actually been shown to have a positive
effect on blood sugar levels for
individuals living with type 2 diabetes
however these effects are mostly true
for fasting blood sugar levels which are
more of a short-term indicator of blood
sugar whereas the effects of cinnamon on
hemoglobin a1c which is more of a
long-term three-month average of blood
sugar levels has shown mixed results
either way you would have to use a fair
bit of cinnamon
to see an impact with one 2013 a
meta-analysis showing improvements in
blood sugars by adding somewhere between
1.2 and 6 grams of cinnamon a day that
could be as little as just over a
quarter of a teaspoon a day but it could
also mean up to two teaspoons that would
be a lot of cinnamon to go through per
person now I love cinnamon I literally
add it to everything myself but more so
as a way to add natural sweetness and
flavor without a lot of added sugar
rather a Bend for the intentional
purpose of lowering my blood sugars
[Music]
let's take a look at her snack so I'm
doing strawberries and I love to pair it
with almonds I love to combine it with
almonds because when you eat your fruit
with something that has fat in there it
helps you to like balance out your blood
sugar also a little side note I'm not a
nutritionist and this is just how I eat
and definitely not every day like
everyone else but yeah this is just the
stuff that I like so keep that in mind
oh my god I think I think Romi legit
heard my commentary on her day one
because she just did exactly what I was
suggesting but for day two and she's
totally right I mean not only do the
fats from the almonds help to control
blood sugars but also the fiber and
protein content also play a really
important role as well however she does
say that eating fruit alone will spike
blood sugar levels which is not entirely
true I don't know if I would use the
word like spiked that sounds pretty
extreme but the impact of fruit on blood
sugar largely depends on its glycemic
index ripeness and the amount of fiber
that that particular fruit contains so
for instance a very ripe banana will
increase blood sugar levels at a faster
rate than let's say an apple or
strawberries in Romy's case either way
if possible I
always do recommend pairing fruit with a
source of fat or protein as a balanced
snack to really boost satiety just as
Romi has done right here also I love the
quick little disclaimer I like that
she's familiar with her own eating
patterns which can be different for
everyone and she even states that she
doesn't eat like this every day but that
this is just generally what she likes
let's hit up lunch day two and the other
half I do a little bit of hummus this
one is already made but I always try to
find a really clean one that doesn't
have too many ingredients if you can
read all the ingredients then you're
good something pepper some sea salt and
some cheese you can also play around
with your seasoning and then it's time
for the egg and then last but not least
I love to add some seeds so these are
sprouted watermelon seeds put it over oh
my gosh that is like the most perfect
sunny-side up egg I have ever seen so
kudos to Romy's man for cooking up that
bad boy but yeah okay so a good avocado
toast with like a stunning egg on top is
personally one of my all-time favorite
lunch or breakfast meals of life and
adding that little bit of hummus as a
spread is totally my style as we know
Romy loves her fat so we've got lots of
healthy fats from the avocado protein
from the egg and a little bit from the
hummus and also some carbs in the bread
I also like to see that she's not
explicitly afraid of oil and even gives
a little tip at one point in the in the
video on crisping up toast in the frying
pan with the oil which oh my gosh this
makes this whole dish sound really
really good now in this long clip
however she does use my least favorite
word of all time clean uh basically
she's talking about shopping for foods
that have whole or recognizable
ingredients which I get and that's smart
but folks can we just scrape clean
from our health vocabulary thank you
very much I mean let's talk about clean
in the context of washing our hands in
this whole coronavirus mess or the state
of your house again in the context of
this whole coronavirus mess but not in
terms of how healthy a food is anyways
we're only also makes another comment
about trying to eat less eggs and meat
but has a hard time not eating it at all
while again she doesn't go into detail
on her rationale for this goal I am glad
to see that she still kind of honors her
preferences to find a balance that still
feels good for her let's take a look at
her snack and everything helps to a
little bit more down at the end of today
otherwise you get cravings later at
night so and I also make myself some tea
okay so I love any opportunity for
sneaking in more veggies and this is a
light relatively lower calorie though
balanced snack so at one point in this
clip Romi mentions that she does like to
have her afternoon snack be lower in
sugar to keep blood Sugar's down at the
end of the day to avoid sugar cravings
later on let's talk about that
[Music]
now I do appreciate her concern around
keeping her blood sugar levels in check
the last thing you actually want to do
to avoid sugar cravings is to keep blood
sugar levels down now low blood sugar
levels may actually trigger the hunger
response and signal to the brain that
it's time to eat so eating a low calorie
snack in some cases might do the
opposite of what Romy is suggesting and
may actually set you up for a late and I
binge or sugar cravings later on in the
day I'm not saying this is the bad snack
I think this is a really great snack if
that's what she felt was satisfying to
her but the information that accompanies
it is just a little bit confused what we
actually want to do is keep our blood
sugar levels even and stable throughout
the day by eating balanced meals and
satisfying snacks regularly from what
we've seen so far Romy is generally
doing a really great job at this by
eating five to six times a day and
including sources of protein and healthy
fats with her carbs
I guess all I'm trying to flag is that
carbs are not the enemy when it comes to
food cravings and cutting them out
completely while still desiring them may
actually backfire on our carb
controlling intentions I don't think
that's what Romy is doing I just wanted
to kind of clear up some of the language
that was used let's take a look at
dinner
it's eggplant from the oven with feta
and foam grenade seeds and it's
something that I think I really like it
also has some rice on the sides this
looks amazing and totally my style while
this meal doesn't have a traditional
protein source we do get some trace
amounts of protein from the eggplant and
small amounts from the feta tzatziki and
seeds which in total provides about 20
grams of protein so that's pretty decent
it also provides a good amount of
calories fat and fiber so if I was
ordering a meal kit I think I'd be
really happy
with this dinner and that's nice because
I don't think all meal kits are
necessarily created equal
now let's finish things off with day
three put it on top and kind of make
like a little open sandwich kindness
okay and then I like ripped the bacon
and they put like bacon bits on it rip
the bacon I mean I think it's really
good but it was very sweet okay so for
Romy's day three meals she's actually
doing something a little bit different
and swapping meals with her friend and
fellow model
jazmyne tooks now she mentions that they
eat very differently so it will be
interesting to see how this goes but as
for breakfast Romy prepares an oatmeal
bowl for Jasmine which is very similar
to the ones that we saw on day two for
example and for Romy's breakfast
Jasmine prepares some scrambled eggs
with bacon and half of a bagel with
butter now romi does mention that she's
trying to limit her meat and her dairy
intake though she doesn't really again
go into a lot of detail on why but I do
appreciate that she's remaining really
flexible with this whole breakfast swap
thing even though it's not necessarily
something that she would probably
normally eat that to me is a really good
sign of having a relaxed relationship
with food now we also see that Romy
brings some digestive enzymes and apple
cider vinegar to the party along with
her to have before her meal to kind of
help her digest her food now when it
comes to digestive enzymes the body
naturally produces its own digestive
enzymes to break down macro nutrients
like protein fat and carbohydrates into
smaller components so that they can be
better absorbed by the body
now digestive enzyme supplements are
often used for pee
with specific conditions like lactose
intolerance or digestive issues like
celiac or IBS or for individuals with
pancreatic insufficiency who are unable
to produce digestive enzymes naturally
however if Romy is able to efficiently
produce enough digestive enzymes on her
own taking a supplement really isn't
necessary to digest a meal like this
especially because she claims that her
oatmeal bowl is heavy and that's why it
warrants enzymatic support now I'm not
exactly sure what supplements she is
brought here but there really are only
two digestive enzyme supplements on the
market whose effectiveness is supported
by research
one of those is lactase aka lactaid for
individuals who are lactose intolerant
so that's a popular one and the other
supplement is alpha galactosidase
otherwise known as Beano this enzyme can
be helpful for people with IBS who may
experience things like gas bloating and
in digestion a lot of the other
combination enzyme products that we see
peddled by Wellness influencers do not
currently have any strong evidence to
back them up and we actually talk a lot
more about that in my bloating video
right here it's also worth mentioning
that there may be some potential side
effects of taking digestive enzyme
supplements including constipation
abdominal cramps nausea and diarrhea as
for the apple cider vinegar there is a
popular theory out there that taking a
shot of apple cider vinegar may improve
digestion or reduce bloating when
consuming a protein heavy meal by
creating more pepsin and pepsin is the
enzyme responsible for a protein
breakdown there's also the thought that
acidic foods could encourage gastric
emptying however there is currently no
evidence to actually support either of
these theories in fact the only study
that I could find on delayed gastric
emptying and apple cider vinegar found
that I may even impair gastric emptying
which in turn could potentially make
bloating worse the acidity in apple
cider vinegar may also erode tooth
enamel and may also cause things like
burping
reflex or nausea now having said that
there may be some small benefits to
consuming apple cider vinegar when it
comes to insulin resistance in diabetes
and PCOS but in general I would say skip
the shots and just incorporate it into
your salad dressings and recipes no I
feel like coffee gets me like a lot of
energy and then I crash yeah I like my
chest more spread okay so in this scene
Romi mentions making the switch from
coffee to matcha and says that she likes
that because she doesn't experience the
same crash with matcha as she does with
coffee and this actually makes a lot of
sense to me this has to do with an amino
acid in matcha called l-theanine which
helps to mediate the effects of caffeine
in the body so basically the l-theanine
and matcha provides the alertness that
we want from caffeine without the crash
that typically follows when we drink a
lot of coffee this is why matcha may
actually provide a milder but more
long-lasting stimulant effect than
coffee so I'm glad that that's something
that Romy's really noticed for herself
and it seems to be working well for her
let's take a look at lunch
[Music]
[Laughter]
for lunch Romy and Jazmin hit up a
vegetarian restaurant after it looks
like a pretty killer workout just before
this and Romy orders a bowl for Jasmine
and Jasmine orders a chimichanga for
Romy
now if I want to really get into ideal
post-workout snacks and meals here I
would say that Romy's choice at the bowl
is probably a better option because the
fat from the chimichanga will likely
slow down the absorption of the protein
and carbs which in turn slows down
muscle and glycogen recovery not a big
deal for recreational training but if we
want it to optimize our post-workout
nutrition that's probably what I would
suggest but let's take a look at dinner
chicken tacos for you okay this must be
your order plantain chips with [ __ ]
movi okay so for Romy's final meal her
and Jasmine order in some Mexican
takeout and for Romy's dinner
Jasmine has chosen some guacamole
Brussels sprouts
spicy corn and chicken tacos and
honestly I am actually pretty shocked
that Romy so she never eats tacos
because tacos are life but hey day three
is all about stepping outside your
comfort zone and living on the edge so I
definitely appreciate that she is kind
of going with the unknown now while all
takeout or restaurant food will likely
be higher in added salt and fat then
likely you would have made at home I
actually think that a lot of Mexican
style food is inherently pretty
well-balanced
you know we've got carbs from the corn
tour
tias protein from things like chicken or
beans healthy fats from the guacamole
and lots of veggies going on as far as
takeout goes it looks pretty tasty and
pretty nutritious in my books and not
restrictive at all so I love that and on
that note let's talk about Romy's
overall diet so in general is this way
of eating balanced overall I'd say that
Romy's way of eating is generally pretty
well balanced I mean she includes a
variety of foods from different food
groups and not only considers the foods
that she likes but also their
nutritional value so I am definitely
seeing a lot of nutrient-dense veggies
some whole grains fats and proteins from
a variety of sources in her meals now
based on our analysis Romi is getting
about 42 to 46 percent of her total
daily calories from fat which is
technically above the recommended 20 to
35 percent macronutrient range for fat
because she is getting most of her
calories from fat her diet does tend to
be lower in carbs so she's getting
around 35 to 45 percent of her total
calories from carbs which is below the
45 to 65 percent macronutrient
recommendations
now despite being lower in carbs her
diet still is pretty high in fiber
around 28 to 62 grams which actually
exceeds her fiber recommendations and
this is mainly because she eats a lot of
avocado and things like Chia as well as
some higher fiber carbs that she does
enjoy like oatmeal now is it an issue
that Romy's diet doesn't fall perfectly
in the recommended macronutrient ranges
um not really in my books it sounds like
this is just the dietary pattern that
feels good to her and it doesn't come
across to me as being restrictive or
like she's specifically calorie or macro
counting she seems to just be eating in
a way that best suits her energy levels
and her digestion which i think is
totally great we're
of her intention I don't get the sense
that Romi is being overly restrictive
with her meals yes she discusses trying
to reduce her meat and dairy intake but
she's not rigid about it as if it's you
know what she's craving and she's pretty
flexible about meals that she didn't
even prepare for instance she was
totally open with the idea of trying new
foods by swapping meals with her friend
and eating from a catering menu even
when she prepared her own healthy meal
so while she may occasionally mention
eating clean and she may make a sincere
effort to build meals and snacks with
nutrition in mind her flexibility to be
able to say man effort your lunch looks
better than mine I'm going to order in
is actually really refreshing I also
want to show a short clip of Romy
discussing how the modeling industry has
really kind of impacted her relationship
with food and her body I felt I was
doing something wrong I felt like I was
disappointing people that had
expectations for me that made me eating
gaining weight okay so based on what
Romy shared I think this is probably a
really common occurrence in the modeling
industry with models feeling intense
pressure to remain a certain weight in
order to maintain their livelihood
luckily the modeling industry has made
some subtle strides towards inclusivity
and body positivity albeit there is
still like a long long ways to go but as
for Romy after going through a repeated
cycle of weight loss and weight regain
and the guilt and shame that was
associated with that it sounds like she
kind of let go of the idea of eating
strictly for weight loss so instead of
trying to live up to these unrealistic
body expectations she kind of tried to
shift her mindset towards eating to make
her feel good and rebuild her
relationship with food
restriction and for the most part I
think we've seen that reflected in a lot
of these videos and I actually really
applaud her bravery in sharing this
now I don't know anything more about
Romy's health or her medical history but
I would just say that it's actually very
common for doctors to miss diagnose
amenorrhea as PCOS when in fact it might
actually be hypothalamic amenorrhea the
diagnostic criteria can actually look
very similar and if doctors are not
doing a deep dive they often just say
that it's PCOS when the profile may
actually fit h ay or hypothalamic
amenorrhea a lot better I'm gonna leave
a blog post below on some of the
diagnostic differences and I've also
covered a che in a little bit more
detail in my video right here but the
reason I bring this up is that I think
this is actually a huge problem in
women's medical space often women with
PCOS are told to limit carbs or calories
and to exercise more which would
ultimately make hae even worse I'm glad
to hear that Romi has not been doing
that of course and I can see that from
her videos but I'm just putting that out
there
that if you've been diagnosed with lean
piece OS definitely ask for a more
comprehensive hormone panel to look at
your LH FSH testosterone the specific
number of follicles and things like that
leading expert dr. nicola Rinaldi who's
the author of no period now what states
that if all androgens are normal or low
and luteinizing hormone is low H a is
strongly suggested she says she wouldn't
personally diagnose PCOS in somebody
meeting some or all of the following
criteria in the absence of physical or
biochemical symptoms of hypo and Rho
Jennison weight loss of 10 pounds or
more at some point in the past being in
a smaller body so the average BMI of a
woman with H a is 19 and that's not to
say that women in different sized bodies
can't have h a because they can but it's
particularly more common in women in the
underweight or low normal BMI range
exercising multiple days per week often
doing high-intensity exercise
restricting amounts of food or avoiding
food groups or feelings psychologically
stressed including stress from trying to
be a picture of health
these are doctor Rinaldi's words
and this actually sounds a lot like what
Romi just described in her video and
feroro me specifically it might be
classic PCOS but I did want to bring
this up as it maybe has not been
adequately explored for a lot of the
viewers who are watching it's also
possible to have PCOS Nha at the same
time but according to fern all D H a
will often mask PCOS symptoms which is
why some people don't present with any
of the traditional PCOS symptoms again I
don't know if Romi has done this and it
sounds like her lifestyle changes alone
have really helped play a role in her
pregnancy success which is amazing
but I'm more flagging this for other
women who may be watching who may also
be struggling to conceive okay back to
the video now of course the other big
question are there any problematic
claims or assumptions made by this
channel well you know unfortunately we
did see a few glimmers of diet culture
rhetoric in Romy's videos so for
instance using some diet culture
terminology often like clean when
describing the hummus uses and several
other times on her channel in reference
to you know items that she's picking up
at Whole Foods or menu options that
she's choosing while at restaurants we
also see Romi being really preoccupied
with staying full as well as taking
unnecessary measures to aid in her
digestion like using apple cider vinegar
or digestive enzymes before her meal and
while I do appreciate that she considers
nutritional value and health benefits of
certain foods and ingredients some of
her assumptions were a little bit
misinformed as for the fullness comments
Romi does frequently mention
incorporating foods like a lot of fats
that she knows will keep her feeling
physically full now I think she means
satisfied which I do believe is a really
important and smart meal consideration I
mean nobody likes to feel like they just
ate a meal and are hungry an hour later
that's that's just annoying and
inefficient right but I also wouldn't
want her or anyone becoming overly
preoccupied with associating certain
foods with being full I want people to
know that it's very normal
and healthy to feel hunger or to not
feel full and it doesn't mean that you
have failed planning that particular
meal or snack diet culture has always
taught us that if you don't feel full
that you're doing something wrong as the
perfect diet is always one that is
promoted as making you feel full all the
time
likewise it's a common diet tactic to
find ways to constantly trick your body
into thinking that it's full whether
that's through drinking a liter of water
before lunch or filling up on clear
broth or just eating like a mountain of
vegetables to stretch your stomach for
not many calories again I don't think
this is what Romi is suggesting that we
do in fact I think what she means is
just adding more staying power to her
meals which is smart but because she was
promoting fullness so much throughout
all of her videos I wanted to just flag
this to kind of remind you that hunger
is not something that you need to
necessarily fear more problematically I
do want to talk briefly about some
behaviors Romy discusses when prepping
for some of her model shoots now in one
of her videos Romy documents what she
does to prep 24 hours before a
Victoria's Secret photo shoot included
in her 24 hour prep routine is a
cryotherapy session now for those of you
unfamiliar with cryotherapy it's a
procedure where the body is exposed to
extremely cold air for several minutes
now I'm Canadian so I am a pro at
navigating negative degree temperatures
but actually paying to stand in a
chamber where cold air shooting at me is
a hard pass but let's take a look at her
routine oh okay so at one point here
Romy mentions that cryotherapy helps to
burn calories assists with pain relief
is anti-inflammatory and gives her
energy and while there may be some
health benefits linked to cryotherapy
particularly for pain relief and
exercise recovery there isn't a ton of
great research to support the claims as
for weight loss the theory is that brown
adipose tissue in our body
aka brown fat burns fats to make energy
when the body is exposed to extreme cold
temperatures while 1 2016 study found
that 3 minutes at negative 166
Fahrenheit twice a day for 5 days did
not result in any weight or fat changes
in men other studies found that about
two hours daily may reduce body fat by
two percent with another study seeing up
to 3 percent
that may sound convincing but two hours
of your day and we do not know how long
these results last if at all the FDA has
also even warned of the lack of evidence
for cryotherapy and cautions towards the
possible side effects including numbness
and skin irritation also a cryotherapy
session will cost you about $100 a pop
so I don't know I guess if you have a
lot of time on your hands and cash any
other Victoria's Secret Show coming up
then maybe it's worth a try but I am not
convinced that this is a realistic fat
loss plan for most people let's see what
else
yes for like information and the
retention of water
[Music]
so next Romney goes to the spa for
lymphatic drainage and a magnesium body
wrap which the masseuse says is for
inflammation and bloating we have
actually already talked about lymphatic
drainage on my channel before which you
can check out right here there is
research on its use for athletes for
post-traumatic edema or swelling an
injury rehab for like fractures and
sprains which of course does make sense
to me but not so much for bloating now
it is possible that it can help with
general bloating a bit by like pushing
gas through the digestive tract but I'm
sure this is not a cheap procedure as
for the magnesium wraps magnesium is a
natural laxative when consumed orally
but there's actually no good evidence
that magnesium is absorbed through your
skin into your body so I'm not sure that
this is gonna do much
the rapp plus sauna combo will likely
induce a lot of sweating which may help
you look temporarily slimmer for a show
but obviously these effects will go away
as soon as you rehydrate or you eat they
may also be dangerous as it could
potentially result in severe dehydration
and electrolyte imbalances so it's not
something that I would ever recommend to
the general population considering the
risk short term impact and of course the
expense and on that note finally what
good can we take away from Romy's
channel well again I actually really
liked Romy's flexibility with food while
she does have her preferences she's not
totally married to them and will still
eat things like eggs or bacon for
breakfast even if that's not something
that she would normally love eating I
also didn't get the sense that she was
overly preoccupied with weight or
calories or restricting certain foods
she also did share some really great
valid nutritional information which as a
dietitian always excites me and her
meals do look really good like
girl hit me up with that avocado toast
thank you very much
bottom line despite admitting that she's
felt some pressure from the modeling
industry to kind of stay within a
certain weight class I really do
appreciate Romy's generally balanced
approach to eating like she says it
doesn't seem like she's eating to lose
weight rather she eats based on what
makes her feel good which is ultimately
in my opinion the most important factor
when it comes to eating and creating a
positive relationship with food even if
you do wear lingerie on stage for
millions of people for a living I know a
lot of us have assumptions around models
following really restrictive diets and
sometimes following extreme weight loss
regimens or detoxes I mean yes her
modeling show prep is really extreme and
potentially dangerous but I am glad that
we're not seeing a lot of overt
restriction happening on the day-to-day
with Romy
I think Romy usually sets a generally
good example to her followers and shows
us that you can eat the foods that you
really like in a balanced and healthy
way without necessarily having to
restrict calories or cut out full food
groups if you don't want to and on that
note that is all for today's video thank
you again to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it that thumbs up leave me a
comment below with who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]